Warren,
Keith Ellison,
real hard left progressive stuff.
It is rooted in identity politics,
which I,
you know we've done already,
but like it is rooted in something that separates us.
It is rooted that you should that even today.
Did you see this?
That Harvard,
I just tweeted out when I was on the way here,
Harvard released this statement of defending the fact that they are okay with
basically having quotas that work against Asian students because they want to
have more other minorities basically meaning black or Hispanic minorities.
So think about it.
Why would you discriminate if you are hiring right now,
let's say you're hiring today,
right?
You're hiring for your studio,
you're going to hire,
you can hire the most qualified person.
Are you going to try to figure out every little identity thing to figure out who
you should hire?
Diversity,
Bro,
I'm all about diversity.
Exactly that it's racist against Asians.
Just [inaudible] been very vocal about it cause they,
they tend to just put their fucking nose to the grindstone and keep ticking out.
So they have to use that against them.
Now that works.
So that's the new thing.
You will not be a,
if you're Asian and you,
and why did they,
why did Asian Americans are Indian Americans are a great example that they have
succeeded at every level that we measure success.
I think the highest socioeconomic average salary over a hundred grand,
you know,
education,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
If you now say,
well wait a minute,
these people played by the rules,
they came here as it most,
you know,
like,
like all of our ancestors virtually came here pretty much with nothing.
People in small businesses busted their ass,
worked in coal mines.
It's that wherever you had to do it,
if you do all of those things,
and then you focus on education and on family and all of those things,
and now the system is gonna say,
well,
it worked for a while,
but we're going to have to put you at the bottom of the thing now.
And you guess what?
You're not going to get into Harvard because you're Asian.
That is racism.
So I've been calling this out for at least two years,
that the next move by this identity politics,
this evil oppression Olympics machine is that they will come after Asian people
and it's starting to happen now.
So I see all these minorities,
by the way.
So Candice,
who I watched the show and I know you guys definitely have disagreements on
stuff as do I do when it comes not only to politics but tactics sometimes and
stuff,
but I really do like her.
Um,
you know,
look,
she's causing a massive rift in the black community and you can see it in the
numbers.
Black male support for Trump or for Trump doubled it was at 11%.
It's tiny too.
No one.
Well,
it's Kanye.
Kanye was the wrecking machine.
But I actually think,
I think in the grand scheme of things can't,
Candace is much bigger.
I really believe that in terms of,
because I think she could be a direct line to all of the political parts of this
if she decides to go that route because I think she could,
I think she could run for Senate or,
yeah.
Yeah.
I can't,
I'm not,
I'm not high today.
I'm only smoking maybe once a week on Sundays and now and now I'm on tour so I'm
not really at all.
But I'll spark up a joint and have you reconsidered what you just said.
You can smoke a joint and maybe I'll reconsider.
Send you watch the podcast I did with her.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
I watch.
I don't maybe at least at least an hour and a half of it or so.
Yeah.
Why?
What?
I don't know why saying it that way.
Cause I don't think she should run for Senate.
No,
no.
I'm not saying she's a young girl with some interesting ideas and she's got a
lot of passion.
I didn't say you think she should.
I even say,
I think she said,
I think she could have a bigger effect.
Even then Kanye,
when it comes to just everything going on politically.
This girl,
she wants it.
She wants it,
man.
I'm sure she does.
But when you share affecting people in a big way,
I think maybe in a bigger way than,
than perhaps either one of us understand.
But my,
but forgetting Candace specifically my point,
my point was nice person.
Yeah.
My point was though that I think all minority groups are reevaluating what's
going on here.
If you're in the black community,
clearly there is at the moment a reevaluation of do we have to be democratic?
If you're,
that is an issue.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a racist issue.
Yes.
Because people assume that if you're black,
you must be a democrat.
If you're not,
you're some sort of an uncle Tom.
Yeah.
It's kind of fucked up.
Talk to my friends Larry Elder.
I had Thomas all on the show or my buddy David Webb or,
or many of,
there are many black conservatives.
Sure.
You are allowed to think however you want despite your skin color.
Right.
So I think the black community,
Ben Carson,
I mean,
I think the black community starting to split,
I think the gay community starting to split because the left has sort of had
this odd embracement of Islam,
which is bad for gays.
So I think the gays are starting to split.
I think that,
uh,
Latinos are even starting to split a little bit differently because I think for
all the people that came here legally,
they're actually not as thrilled with illegal immigration as the media may imply
that they are.
So I think there's just massive shifts happening all over the place.
And the way we look at voting where every election,
you know,
what's his name?
John King goes on CNN and shows you the map and it goes,
well,
the white working class people here voted this way and the black inner city
people.
But I think all of that is about to explode.
And they won't know what to do because they haven't been listening.
But I think some others have them.
Listen.